[Musica]
[Applauso]
poi preferito a tutti e benvenuti sul
pianeta c'erano sì è proprio lui perché
è così che dovrebbe essere chiamato il
nostro pianeta visto che il 71 per cento
della sua superficie è coperta da quello
che i nostri occhi appare con un immenso
infinito velo blu e infatti i nostri
occhi spesso si fermano alla superficie
del mare per carità
già quella in grado di farci sognare
assecondiamo andare oltre se ci
immergiamo scopriamo la vita al più
vasto
per carità che ospita ambienti
straordinari e tende dell'ottanta per
cento delle specie viventi noi sulla
terra ferma
se a me netta minoranza ad oggi abbiamo
esplorato solo il 5 per cento degli
oceani pensate dobbiamo mappe più
dettagliate di marte e della luna
rispetto ai fondali amici però in quella
piccola percentuale
abbiamo trovato un mondo nuovo tra cui
già era dorsale medio atlantica
la catena montuosa più lunga del pianeta
e sottomarino 15.000 km
e poi paesaggi che vanno ben al di là
della nostra immaginazione come cascate
e la keys la ue e poi abbiamo trovato la
vita proprio in fondo al mare dove la
luce non vede tra ed è per questo che
pensavamo che non ci fosse a tema vino e
invece abbiamo trovato più di
biodiversità che nella foresta tropicale
almeno tanto quanto è nelle barriere
coralline e autonomi esplorazione ad
ogni immersione scopriamo specie di
lucera è la linfa vitale del nostro
pianeta
ovunque tu sia qualsiasi cosa tu stia
facendo la tua esistenza dipende dal
mare
[Musica]
non solo perché negli oceani è nata la
lista effettivamente anche questo
diciamo che c'è cormor importante è che
in oceani regolari turchino e la
temperatura del nostro pianeta e forse
non tutti sanno critiche video ce ne
sono anche il polmone fronte del nostro
pianeta
il 50 per cento dell'ossigeno che
respiriamo viene da loro bene dal male
che anche in grado di assorbire un terzo
dell'anidride carbonica
bruciamo senza dimenticare che io c'era
nessuna fonte fondamentale di reddito di
cibo e di energia per miliardi di
persone
questo ruolo importantissimo che gli
ocelli giocano spesso è sconosciuto
oppure dato per scontato ed è per questo
che è fondamentale per chi si occupa di
conservazione dell'ambiente marino
comunicarlo accompagnare le persone
attraverso le parole attraverso le
immagini alla scoperta di un mondo
straordinario di ambienti e di creature
che ci sono in grado di lasciarci
letteralmente a bocca bella e vi faccio
qualche esempio
e ammette una mia debolezza perché tra
tutte del cantù green marine che
esistono viola debole per uno e questa
creatura apple paul il polpo è non
importa mi raccomando perché polipo e
invece l'aveva detto del coraggio
il colpo è il mio animale preferito
giocare leone intelligentissimo curioso
e poi non a puro ma ben tre fuori e per
me che sono
un'eterna romantica non fossi metterò
master è già praticamente persa tra le
sue otto braccio e poi il polpo anche un
superpotere la sua pelle con sforza di
celle che sono in grado di fargli
cambiare colore in un batter d'occhio e
fargli assumere la serie le sembianze
dell'ambiente che lo circonda
mimetizzandosi quasi completamente fino
a diventare ad esigere beh ho giocato le
mie carte
sapete che sono una romanticona ed è per
questo che voglio condividere con voi
un'altra storia di un'altra creatura
straordinaria e questa volta è una
storia d'amore
stiamo parlando del cavalluccio marino
tutto inizia con un corteggiamento che
il romanzo d'amore dell'ottocento
cavalluccio maschio e belloccia femmina
si incontrano ogni mattina all'alba e
bastano la giornata insieme aiutandosi
ancora fianco spesso con le code
intrecciate per poi congedarsi al
tramonto e ritrovarsi all'alba del
questo corteggiamento va avanti diverse
settimane e quando arriva il momento di
andare al sodo il cavalluccio maschio si
gioca la sua carta migliore cioè quella
di mostrare la sua pancia a cavalluccio
fede e altro canto suo pancione
fondamentale perché proprio di che la
femmina depone le sue uova poi del
cavaticcio maschera divertiti ed e
custodisce nel suo pancione per tre
settimane al termine delle quali è
proprio lui a dare alla luce i piccoli
di cavalluccio marino è l'evoluzione
abbiamo tutto da imparare
assolutamente a parte gli scherzi a
parte di singoli casi degni di nota
quello che forse mi ha stupito di più
nello studiare l'ambiente marino è che
in mare tutto è interconnesso un sistema
complesso costituito da equilibri
fragili creati e plasmati da centinaia
di migliaia di anni di evoluzione
e se c'è un ambiente e proprio ci aiuta
a immaginarci questo legame così forte
con l'ambiente è la barriera corallina
le barriere coralline sono come le
nostre grandi metropoli no pensate che
occupano lo 0,01 per cento dei fondali
marini ma ospitano eventi 500 della
biodiversità marina praticamente una su
quattro non esisterebbe se non ci
fossero le barriere coralline
incredibile ma proprio quello che ancora
più dell'incredibile è fatto che
nell'organismo alla base della barriera
corallina decorarlo non c'è anche questo
legame the sun infatti il famoso polico
del coraggio vive in simbiosi con delle
alghe microscopiche che si chiamano jobs
santelle questo anche solo
responsabilizza di 90 per cento del suo
nutrimento
il problema nasce quando il coraggio si
trova sotto stress e quando il corano si
trova sotto stress per esempio perché
aumenta la temperatura dell'acqua e si
spende queste alghe e visto che sono
non sapere una volta per cento del suo
nutrimento ha pochissime possibilità di
recupero la relazione tra polipo del
coraggio e alghe microscopiche dura da
pensate 160 milioni zia ma da
cinquant'anni a questa parte le cose
stanno cambiando e purtroppo non solo
per il pareggio
le condizioni chimico fisiche i nostri
oceani stanno cambiando in maniera
drastica e ha una velocità mai
registrata prima d'ora fino a qualche
anno fa quando si parlava di cambiamenti
climatici l'occhiello non veniva
praticamente quasi umano nominato dagli
atti si no perché l'oceano è stato fino
ad oggi il nostro più grande alleato
alla lotta ai cambiamenti climatici
sappiamo tutti che i cambiamenti
climatici sono causati dalla presenza
la serra in atmosfera che trattengono il
calore
bene ora vi dico qualcosa di importante
assolutamente da ricordare
dalla rivoluzione industriale ad oggi
l'oceano assorbito il 93 per cento
il calore in eccesso trattenuto dai
castelli se non ci fosse stato l'oceano
la temperatura della terra oggi sarebbe
di 36 gradi superiore quindi oggi a
rovigo che ci sono 28 gradi ne avremo 64
altro che riscaldamento globale
saremmo veramente tutti i costi
assolutamente questo è importante ma
anche delle conseguenze
c'è sempre un prezzo da pagare la prima
conseguenza
abbiamo registrato un aumento delle
temperature delle altre fino a 2000
metri di profondità è tantissimo e poi
anche altri cambiamenti come per esempio
di intensificazione di fenomeni
metereologici gravi come ti poni cicloni
ma anche siccità estreme incendi
per non parlare della fusione dei
ghiacciai e del conseguente innalzamento
del livello del mare
sembrerebbe già abbastanza eppure lui
c'erano deve andare deve far fronte a un
altro problema altrettanto grave che è
quello lette l'acidificazione delle sue
acque che deriva proprio dalla sua
capacità di assorbire anidride carbonica
dall'atmosfera che si trasforma in
oceano in acido carbonico dalla
rivoluzione industriale ad oggi c'erano
il 16 per cento fiocine ma le proiezioni
sono drammatiche perché se andiamo
avanti così a fine secolo saranno dei
170 per cento più acide con quelli di
quella di acidità e di via i coralli
praticamente si sciolgono
non a caso questi grandi cambiamenti di
temperatura e acidità al passato sono
stati associati con le grandi estinzioni
di massa
ed è così che quello che una volta erano
le bende barriere coralline le nostre
metropoli affollate per metà sono
ridotte a 1 18 li lasciamo senza un
posto dove vivere
migliaia di abitanti oltre a questi
cambiamenti a livello chimico fisico la
cena per fare con altri infatti è uno
sicuramente quello dell'inquinamento
ci sono varie tipologie di inquinamento
e tutte gravi ma ce n'è una in
particolare di cui si pagano molto
ultimamente e dell inquinamento della
plastica in aria ogni anno 8 milioni
tonnellate di plastica finiscono in mare
questo equivale a un camion della
spazzatura pieno di plastica che diversa
il suo contenuto in mare ogni libro x
tutti i minuti che abbiamo in ogni
giorno e per tutti i giovani che abbiamo
non hanno una ricerca molto importante
presentata in occasione del tour asp
economy forum
qualche anno fa sui non chiaro
campanello
se continua ad andare avanti così
nel 2050 a parità di peso
gli oceani incontrarlo più plastica che
dice e non possono terminare questo
racconto dell'orrore che però è doveroso
con un altro impatto importante che è
quello della sovrappesca e della pesca
illegale perché sono le cause principali
tra le cause principali della perdita di
biodiversità animale e della distruzione
degli habitat
il ragionamento è molto semplice il
nostro sforzo di pesca l'intensità
peschiamo è nettamente maggiore della
capacità del pesce di riprodursi in
questo modo entrano in un circolo
vizioso che come dice la fao food and
agricultural organization delle nazioni
unite ci porterà al collasso totale
della festa commerciale nel 2050 insomma
2050 è un anno si preannuncia come anno
nefasto e non è ancora arrivato e già
vogliamo dimenticarci però
ed è il nostro countdown è che abbiamo
ancora 32 anni e cambiare rotta si può
sappiamo quali sono le soluzioni abbiamo
gli strumenti abbiamo le tecnologie
quello che ancora ci manca è una grande
forza di volontà per metterle in atto
c'è un'altra buona notizia e dentro
c'erano ha una capacità in immensa di
rigenerarsi solo serino lasciamo fare e
possiamo lasciarglielo fare attraverso
quelle che si chiamano le aree marine
protette delle vere equa e proprio in
polizze assicurative per il futuro del
nostro oceano e della sua biodiversità
nelle oasi dove decimo riprodursi e
ripopolare da croci costante permettendo
arginando riacquisire equilibrio perduto
nelle aree marine protette ben gestite e
progettate succede qualcosa di
straordinario
aumenta il pesce del 166 per cento a
metà che la biodiversità
abbiamo il 21 per cento di specificare
e un ambiente criticate san grato di far
fronte a cambiamenti globali stress
globali in una maniera più significativa
e poi delle aree marine protette i pesci
sono più grandi e il pesce più grande
non è che sono solo più belli da vedere
ma anche sono in grado di produrre più
nuova pensate che invece di 40
centimetri e un peso di 60 cm di quello
di 60 cm produce due miliardi di uova in
più rispetto a quello di 40 centimetri
ma i benefici della protezione
dell'ambiente marino non si limita la
guerra perché possano essere un
importante volano di sviluppo sociale ed
economico per le popolazioni locali
infatti aumentano grazie ad aree marine
protette anche le catture dove si può
pescare dal 50 al 90 per cento
numeri straordinari e aumentano anche i
ricavi per l'economia
i locali una importante ricerca fatta
nell'area marina protetta di paul cro in
francia ha dimostrato che per ogni euro
che lo stato investe nell'area marina
protetta questa in grado di generare 92
per la comunità
quindi l'investimento degno di nota
soprattutto oggi in tempi di crisi ma
voglio darmi un'altra ragione di
speranza che questa ragione sui giovani
le nuove generazioni io ho la fortuna di
essere parte di un network di giovani
professionisti della commissione
mondiale delle aree protette della
insieme con i guai
condivido la grande passione per la
conservazione della natura ma anche le
frustrazioni del mestiere ma soprattutto
è un network che mi stimola e mi motiva
a fare meglio e la mia parte per la
tutela del patrimonio naturale
paese ed è così che cinque anni fa ho
fondato un'associazione che si occupa
proprio di conservazione valorizzazione
dell'ambiente marino ma anche di
potenziamento professionale dei giovani
con lavoro se giochiamo di aree marine
protette pesca sostenibile educazione
ambientale turismo responsabile e
soprattutto facciamo dei percorsi nelle
scuole di sensibilizzazione delle nuove
generazioni sull'inquinamento della
plastica in mare
e questa è una delle cose che ci da più
soddisfazione perché i risultati sono
questi
[Musica]
pensavo che ci è piaciuta questa
plastica i nostri mali 13 chili e mezzo
di plastica in 100 metri quadrati
a me non sembra gente normale io ho
ragione io comincerei a ragionare se
fossi qui ognuno deve dare una mano deve
fare la sua parte
[Musica]
ridere con una citazione un'agitazione
di una persona che vedete in questa foto
fantastica fenomenale d'acqua oltre 40
anni prima linea per l'esplorazione la
conservazione dell'ambiente marino ne
dice 50 anni fa pensavamo che non ci
fossero limiti a quello che potevamo
immettere e prelevare dal mare tra 50
anni sarà troppo tardi per fare ciò che
invece possibile sarà adesso siamo in un
punto cruciale della storia un momento
unico le decisioni che prenderemo le
casse i dieci anni andranno a
determinare la direzione lo svolgimento
dei prossimi 10 mila ricordiamocelo
ognuno di noi può e deve fare la sua
parte e soprattutto tutti possiamo
decidere di stare dalla parte del mare
grazie
[Applauso]